- Wow.
Bro, this is me living my best life.
Hey, what's up, y'all?
I'm KYLE.
♪ Girl I know you playing with me ♪
♪ Girl who are you playing with ♪
Super Duper Kyle, that is my alter ego,
that is the version of
myself that is unstoppable.
- Hi, my name is Karl Altstaetter,
and I've been a comic
book artist for 25 years,
and I'm here to turn
KYLE into the superhero
he's always imagined he could be.
Tell me about your superhero alter ego.
- KYLE is kind of like
a shy, nerdy drama kid,
and then Super Duper Kyle
was his voice in his head
that's like 'nah, dude,
you're a superstar.'
- [Karl] What's his
most prominent feature?
- He's got these big ass
teeth, and he goes like this,
like big as hell, and they
just shine dummy bright,
like (high-pitched humming),
and then people are like (screaming) gosh.
He's gotta be kinda swole.
Can you make me semi-swole?
- Absolutely.
- He's definitely swole.
I would love to go just
fly high up into the clouds
and kinda just get away from everything
and just be able to look
down at the sky and just,
you know, chill.
And he's a little tall,
you know what I mean?
Not too tall, but he's kinda tall.
Attractive.
Yes.
Wow.
Oh my God (laughs).
Yo, dude, this is crazy.
- Well, one of the things you mentioned
that really resonated with me
was you flying above
everything in a positive way,
and that's really what
I wanted to capture.
So, there's sort of the gray
clouds and the city here,
and you're sort of above it.
- Yeah.
- Going towards sort of
the positive energy up top.
- This made me think a
lot about the, you know,
the person I'm trying to
be, you know what I mean?
Even more than what I am today,
I think I wanna leave
this room and try and be
more of this version of myself.
Everybody is somebody's superhero,
and based on how you act
out there in the world,
you know what I mean?
Depends on who's gonna say
that about you one day.
This was eye-opening, dude, and this is...
This is tight.
Wait, can I show it to the...
Can I touch it?
I'm sorry.
- Go ahead.
- Bro, this is (bleep) epic.
(laughing)
(inspirational music)